britney spears is actively challenging
the conservatorship that has dominated
every aspect of her life since 2008 but
why well reportedly the conservator that
is the guy in charge of her life was
making ten thousand dollars a week while
she was only given an allowance of two
thousand dollars
she was forced to get an iud so that she
couldn't have another child
and she was appointed a lawyer who never
told her that she could challenge the
conservatorship
and that is just the tip of the iceberg
i shouldn't be on in a conservatorship
if i can work and provide money and work
for myself and pay
other people brittany testified in a
probate hearing for the first time in
over a decade
and she tells a story about being forced
to perform against her will
he handed me a sheet of paper as i got
off the stage in vegas and said i had to
sign it
it was very threatening and scary and
with the conservatorship i couldn't even
get my own attorney so out of fear
i went ahead and i did the tour and
despite the conservatorship during the
preparations for this tour she took
responsibility for rehearsing and
directing her own dancers
i wasn't good i was great i let a room
of 16 new dancers in rehearsals
it's funny to hear my manager's side of
the story they all said i wasn't
participating in rehearsals
and i never agreed to take my medication
ma'am i'm not here
to be anyone slave i can say no to a
dance move
she also said her conservatorship which
has mostly been directed by her father
jamie spears
refuses to allow her to marry and have
children i want to be able to get
married and have a baby
i was told right now on the
conservatorship i'm not able to
get married or have a baby i have a um
id inside of myself right now so i don't
get pregnant
i wanted to take the id out so i could
start trying to have another baby
but this so-called team won't let me go
to the doctor
to take it out because they they don't
want me to have children
the things britney said about her
conservatorship are harrowing and
include allegations of abuse
and there are of course circumstances
when a court-appointed conservator is
given the right to assume responsibility
for someone else's life decisions and
that makes sense
although britney's conservatorship was
originally based on her own mental
health crisis
one would assume it takes more than that
to maintain a legal conservatorship
for more than a decade over a seemingly
functional adult but we don't have to
look very hard to find people who have
repeatedly filed for bankruptcy or
have had very public mental health
crises or have had a serious drug habit
and caused their life to spiral out of
control
and even those who were being
manipulated and conned out of their
money
but none of these people have been
subjected to a conservatorship the kind
that
britney spears has been under for a
decade so what does it take for a court
to put a person
under a general conservatorship and why
does britney spears want to end this
conservatorship in her case
well today i'm going to tell you
everything you need to know about what
is happening to britney spears
[Music]
hey league legals it's time to think
like a guardian ad litem because britney
spears has been
under a conservatorship for over a
decade so
what is a conservatorship well a
conservatorship is a court-appointed
arrangement in which a person or
organization is chosen to
protect and manage the finances and at
times the personal care of someone
whom a judge has found to be unable to
manage their own affairs
a conservator is responsible for using
their judgment to arrange for the care
and protection of the person under the
conservatorship
the person under the conservatorship is
known as the conservative
now there are a few different kinds of
conservatorships under california law
britney spears has been under a general
conservatorship since 2008. this is
governed by the california probate court
there are conservatorships of adults who
cannot handle their finances personal
care or both
this consists of two parts conservative
ships of the estate
and conservatorships of a person a
conservator of the estate is appointed
to administer the person's financial
life such as
investing the person's money protecting
their assets paying their bills and
budgeting for expenses
a conservator of the person takes charge
of the person's non-financial life now
the specifics differ depending on each
person's circumstances but generally a
conservator can decide
where the person will live whether they
receive an allowance and whether they
can make their own personal care and
health decisions
general conservatorships have no
termination date they can
and usually do last until the end of the
person's life
but at the same time the vast majority
of these conservatorships involve the
elderly or the infirm
people that manifestly cannot take care
of themselves so
it's not something that lasts 50 years
it might be something that lasts five
years until they pass away
but let's talk about the scope of
conservatorships because
once a conservatorship is established
the limitations on a conservative's
freedom are
incredibly broad as disability rights
lawyer patricia cavey points out quote
in many ways the deprivation of liberty
through an involuntary guardianship
order
is greater than that suffered by a
convicted felon
prisoners retain basic rights to control
medical decisions bodily integrity and
the right to conduct their business
affairs and retain their estate
wards do not the due process protections
of the 14th amendment apply to
guardianships and conservatorships
but due process only guarantees the
right to notice and
a court hearing the supreme court has
never decided a case establishing the
precise parameters of due process in the
context of guardianships or
conservatorship this means that there is
no universal requirement that people who
are subject to conservatorship
proceedings
have specific rights like a sixth
amendment right to an attorney
most states require or allow the
appointment of a lawyer but they don't
necessarily let the conservative choose
their own lawyer once a conservatorship
is established
the costs of administering the person's
life are paid
by the conservative the person who is
under the care of these other people
this doesn't automatically mean that
there's a conflict of interest but it's
something that britney flagged when she
spoke in court the fact
that her family lives off of her fortune
and her performances provide a living
for many people creates a conflict of
interest
it's been a long time since i've owned
my money and it's my wish and my dream
for all of this to end
without being tested again it makes no
sense whatsoever for the state of
california to sit back and literally
watch
me with their own two eyes make a living
for so many people
and pay so many people trucks and buses
on tour on the road with me
and be told i'm not good enough but i'm
great at what i do
so that brings us to the very obvious
question of who is able to initiate a
conservatorship over another adult
well any person who wants to be a
conservator can file a petition for
conservatorship
this could be a spouse a relative a
friend or even a manager
and under the law the court gives
preference to certain people a spouse
adult children parent sibling or another
person
and in spear's case her father jamie
spears filed a petition for temporary
conservatorship
in 2008. this was later converted to a
general conservatorship and he sought
and received the right to manage the
estate and her person
attorney andrew wallet was later named
co-conservator
and now why was brittany's father
appointed as a conservator well
because she was not married at the time
there was no one else higher on the
priority list and it's possible for the
same person to become
conservator of both the estate and the
person to be appointed as both
separate petitions have to be filed so
what is the legal standard to
force another adult person into a
conservatorship
well california probate code section
1821 requires the initial petition to
show the following number one
the inability of the proposed
conservative to properly provide for his
or her needs for physical health food
clothing and shelter
two the location of the proposed
conservatives residents and the ability
of the proposed conservative to live
in the residence while under
conservatorship three
alternatives to conservatorship
considered by the petitioner
or proposed conservator and reasons why
those alternatives are not available
number four health and social services
provided to the proposed conservative
during the year preceding the filing of
the petition
and number five the inability of the
proposed conservative to substantially
manage his or her own financial
resources
or to resist fraud or undue influence
this
is and frankly should be a very high bar
for the petitioner to clear
the facts need to show that the person
is not capable of taking care of
themselves
or of managing their own finances or
that they are susceptible to
manipulation
now in the case of britney spears we
don't know exactly what the facts were
that the court relied on when it
determined that britney needed a
conservatorship back
in 2008 when jamie spears petitioned the
probate court
britney had been through enormous
upheaval in a very short period of time
britney was harassed repeatedly by the
paparazzi she publicly shaved her head
shortly after the death of a beloved
aunt
and this event was captured by cameras
and became an enormous tabloid story
she was also in a divorce and in a
custody battle with kevin fetterline
she had voluntarily gone to rehab and
done two stints in a psychiatric
institution
we assume that she has a disability but
we don't know whether she has any
psychiatric diagnosis
now jamie spears also told the court
that britney's new manager sam lufty
was abusing her and the court in these
proceedings entered a restraining order
against
lufty now while we don't have all of
this information
i don't think anyone seriously
questioned the necessity of the spears
conservatorship
at the time however in retrospect it's
fair to ask whether the spears family
could have used a less restrictive
measure to protect brittany or
whether this conservatorship has gone on
for way too long
now what are some less restrictive
measures that could have been instituted
well
for starters a power of attorney where a
person legally authorizes an individual
to make
financial decisions for them this could
be a spouse a friend a manager or even a
lawyer
a person might also agree to give
temporary custody to their children to
their ex
giving someone power of attorney allows
them to make decisions on your behalf
but it doesn't allow them to control
your every waking moment
there can be mediations in court-ordered
rehab when drugs are an issue
and someone who has power of attorney
can create a trust and pay the bills of
their client and
put them on an allowance all of these
are serious steps but they don't compare
to the severity of
a conservatorship but of course
sometimes conservatorship
is necessary now you might ask aren't
there some legal safeguards to make sure
that the conservatorship is
necessary on a continual basis well
there are supposed to be safeguards in
these arrangements
the conservator has to periodically
report to the court about the status of
the situation in some circumstances the
conservator will need
court's approval to make certain
decisions and in the beginning of this
process a court-appointed investigator
is responsible for interviewing the
potential conservative
explaining their rights and making
recommendations to the judge
however after the conservatorship is
established the investigator only speaks
to the conservative
every two years and here jamie spears
maintained full control over brittany
even after sam lufty was gone her
divorce and custody arrangements were
final
and her drug use had apparently ended
public reports show that
jamie quote had the authority to
restrict and limit her visitors oversee
her personal security
and dictate her medical and psychiatric
treatment jamie has repeatedly said that
he only wants what's in her best
interest and that he loves his daughter
and wouldn't force her to do anything
that she wouldn't want to do
but of course the free britney movement
has pointed out cracks in this facade
for years when britney had a successful
run of shows in las vegas
people started to question why a highly
skilled performer was still
under a conservatorship then things
started to unravel publicly in 2019.
in january jaime's original
co-conservator andrew wallett resigned
after asking for a raise
that left jaime spears as the sole
conservator of both spears's person and
estate
the new york times recently reviewed a
transcript of a hearing from the spring
of 2019 when britney's lawyer quote
asserted that she had been forced into
mental health facilities against her
will
on exaggerated grounds which she viewed
as punishment for standing up for
herself and making an objection during a
rehearsal
at the time britney's lawyer filed a
document saying that britney was afraid
of her father and
later in 2019 kevin fetterline backed up
this claim
he helped their teen sons file for a
restraining order against jamie because
of something he did
to one of their children when they
visited with jaime and
federer line's attorney said quote
britney exercised appropriate parental
conduct removing her children from a
dangerous situation
this order was granted without
opposition from jaime and barred him
from
contact with the boys for three years in
september of 2019
jamie spears asked to be released from
managing britney's personal care
the court appointed jody montgomery a
professional conservator
jaime continues in his role as manager
of the estate and he has told the court
that he
opposes ending his conservatorship the
court allowed jaime to take a 1.5
cut of everything britney makes from her
performances
this is in addition to his monthly
salary of 16 000
for acting as conservator and doesn't
include jaime's attorney's fees
which are also paid out of brittany's
estate britney said quote they've done a
good job at exploiting my life
uh talking about her father and
montgomery in june of 2021
when she addressed the court for the
first time so what about the lawyer
well britney has a court-appointed
lawyer samuel d ingram iii
under california probate code section
1470 in 1471
judges are required to appoint counsel
for the proposed conservative in some
situations
most court clerks have a rotating list
of lawyers who serve as court-appointed
counsel now in practice
this means that the person isn't picking
their own lawyer now how can this be
well the basis for conservatorship is
literally the person isn't competent to
enter into contracts
so jamie spears has repeatedly
emphasized his belief that his daughter
is not capable of handling her own
business without being taken advantage
of by other people
and since this is the very foundation of
the conservatorship
a judge can also presume that the person
isn't competent to hire their own lawyer
and ingram told the court in 2020 that
britney wanted her father replaced by
bessemer trust as co-conservator
the bessemer trust is a bank now ingram
told the court that britney was actually
afraid of her father and that in the
future he might file a petition to end
the conservatorship
but despite britney's apparent
discomfort with a conservatorship ingram
never filed a petition to end it
and according to news reports ingram
told the court that britney wanted a
chance to speak but
he had no idea what she would say during
the court hearing britney said that he
never told her she had a right to file a
petition to end the conservatorship
i was told i have to sit down and be
evaluated
again if i want to end the
conservatorship ma'am i didn't know i
could petition the conservatorship to it
and end it i'm sorry for my ignorance
but i honestly didn't know that
i don't feel like i should even be in
room with anyone
to offend me by trying to question my
capacity of intelligence whether i need
to be in this stupid conservatorship or
not
if this is true this could be a serious
ethical lapse because
just because the lawyer is appointed
doesn't mean that they
don't have all of the same ethical
obligations to any client to
zealously represent that client to the
best of their abilities and in the best
interests
of their client and there are other
holes in the record regarding ingram as
well
probate law allows the court to set the
lawyer's fee and to bill it to the
conservatives estate
and ingram right now is making ten
thousand dollars a week in fees as her
lawyer
yet neither he nor the court could
produce the order which established his
rate or allowed him to build that much
it's possible that he was making ten
thousand dollars a week
since 2008. all the while there are
reports that britney was given an
allowance of only two thousand dollars a
week all the while
her estate is worth north of 60 million
dollars
however at the same time britney says
she also has developed a good
relationship with ingram
actually i know i've had grown with a
personal relationship with sam my lawyer
i've been talking to him like three
times
um a week now we've kind of built a
relationship but i haven't really had
the opportunity by my
own self to actually
pan pick my own lawyer by myself
and i would like to be able to do that
it's theoretically possible based on the
size of the estate that these fees are
warranted
it's possible based on the amount of
work that he is doing that these fees
are warranted
but we just don't happen to know the
situation with ingram just isn't clear
but it certainly seems suspicious on its
face and what we're witnessing here
may be true confusion by brittany and
ingram about the lawyer's role
the nature of the conservatorship can
often blur the ethical lines between
advocate and guardian california law
requires lawyers to maintain
confidentiality and loyalty to their
clients and there's no exception for
lawyers appointed to represent
conservatives and in fact
california rejected the proposed rule of
professional conduct which would have
given lawyers some freedom to give their
own opinion about their clients with
diminished capacity for example san
diego lawyers ann rudolph and ralph
hughes
argued that the nature of
conservatorship encourages lawyers to
actually report on their clients to the
court
explaining what they feel is in the best
interest of their client
rather than advocating for what their
clients actually want
they say that this violates a lawyer's
ethical duty to keep attorney-client
communications confidential
and in their view this violates a
lawyer's ethical duty to zealously
advocate for their client a lawyer quote
cannot tell the court what the client
has said without the client's consent
cannot ignore the client's stated
desires and goals and can't advocate
something that the client does not want
so for example this could lead a lawyer
to using the best interest standard to
make decisions about the client's mental
capacity decisions that arguably the
lawyer isn't qualified to make
and in other words a court appointed
lawyer should be an advocate for what
the client wants
not act as a guardian ad litem who
substitutes their own judgment for the
client's wishes
and it's also important to recognize
that despite the we're here to help
attitude
conservatorships are inherently
adversarial they strip people of their
most fundamental rights
now most lawyers would say that the
nature of this process requires lawyers
to be zealous advocates but
in california there are court decisions
allowing lawyers to exercise their
independent judgment on crucial matters
impacting their conservative including
whether to withdraw
life support in cases permitting lawyers
to decide to pull the plug an appeals
court has emphasized that there isn't a
law requiring a court to get involved in
a conservative's decision
to literally withdraw life support this
raises another question
does the court get involved when other
fundamental rights are at stake
like reproduction well we sort of have
an example
in the case of britney spears because
choosing whether
and when to have children is a
fundamental constitutional right that
includes
the right of procreation sterilization
and abortion yet
coerce sterilization in the u.s has a
long and horrible legal history
in 1927 oliver wendell holmes one of the
most respected jurists of all time wrote
one of the most shocking supreme court
opinions ever in buck vs bell which
upheld virginia's eugenical
sterilization act
this law allowed the state to forcibly
sterilize carrie buck
a poor woman that the state had said
should not be able to have children
the opinion is infamous because holmes
wrote three generations of imbeciles
is enough kerry buck actually didn't
have any discernible disability but her
foster family initiated a court
proceeding against her
after their nephew sexually assaulted
her the case is a lesson on how easy it
could be to convince a court to take
away a person's freedom it's also a
lesson
in even respected jurists on the supreme
court
get things horribly horribly wrong and
after buck versus bell america
sterilized about 70
000 people and in this case brittany
told the court
i wanted to take the id out so i could
start trying to have another baby
but this so-called team won't let me go
to the doctor
to take it out because they they don't
want me to have children
this means that at some point she got an
iud that prevents pregnancy but when she
decided that she'd like to have another
child
her conservatorship run by her father
refused to allow her to see a doctor
about taking it out
we don't know whether there was ever a
hearing regarding britney's iud but the
rules of conservatorship do not
expressly require one
even though it obviously impacts a
fundamental right
just as no california statute or
decision purports to require judicial
approval of a conservator's decision to
forego further medical treatment
there's no statute requiring judicial
approval of a conservator's decision to
limit a conservative's reproductive
choices
the conservative ship is broad and
powerful since medical decisions are
part of the conservatorship of the
person
britney has no final say over her own
medical treatment including whether she
uses birth control
and this court has delegated power to
conservatives so it takes a hands-off
role
unless there is a petition to terminate
the conservatorship
so let's talk about whether it's
possible to end a conservatorship and
whether it should be
ended one of the reasons that the spears
conservatorship started to get attention
was because brittany's activities
seem to undermine jaime's assertions
that she needed it in the first place
and let's just look at what britney has
done over the last
13 years she's released four albums
served as a judge on a reality show and
performed
hundreds of shows during a las vegas
residency judging by her work britney is
in a very different place than she was
in 2008.
why is a woman who is not yet 40 with a
full-time and very demanding job
who shares custody of two children still
under a conservatorship
remember this isn't about being bad with
money or using drugs or
refusing to go to therapy or anything
else that a lot of other americans may
struggle with for the conservatorship to
be necessary the person must still be
unable to manage their affairs
full stop the legal standard remains
that a person is unable to provide for
their basic needs like food
clothing shelter and be incapable of
making medical decisions
for financial decisions the requirement
is a person being unable to manage their
financial affairs or resist
undue influence but here's the problem
the burden isn't on the conservator to
establish the continuing need for
conservatorship
the burden is instead on the
conservative to prove that they don't
need it and although it may seem pretty
simple to make this showing
i'm not sure how easy it is now if you
aren't capable of cooking for yourself
and want to avoid getting put in a
conservatorship
you've got to try hello fresh oh god
that's so mean
now i have to say i was initially pretty
skeptical about hellofresh i'm a pretty
good cook so i didn't think that i
needed the help
but i actually loved it even for an
experienced cook hellofresh provides new
ingredients and recipes that i would
never have tried on my own
everything i've gotten has been insanely
delicious easy to cook and
actually really healthy and most
recently i made yogurt marinated chicken
with garlic sauce and steakhouse pork
chops both were incredibly delicious and
not something i would normally make on
my own
if you feel like you've been cooking the
same thing every day in quarantine
hellofresh is a great solution
and of course everything was delivered
straight to my door so i didn't have to
do any shopping
the produce actually gets to you faster
than in a grocery store so it arrives at
peak freshness and flavor
and it's also super easy and saves time
hello fresh cuts out meal planning and
prep so the recipes take only 20 to 30
minutes to cook
literally less time to cook than it
would normally take to do the shopping
and it's also really sustainable since
the ingredients are pre-portioned
there's less prep and less wasted food
the packaging is almost entirely made
from recyclable or already recycled
content
and hellofresh's carbon footprint is
actually 25 lower
than meals that you would make from
store-bought groceries
so if you want to try hellofresh go to
hellofresh.com and use the code
legaleagle14
to get 14 free meals yeah 14 free meals
plus
free shipping so again for 14 free meals
go to hellofresh.com and use the code
legaleagle14
or click on the link in the description
plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel so do you
agree with my analysis about
the whole britney situation leave your
objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other videos about the
legal issues in the news so click on
this playlist
or i'll see you in court